[Music]
straight ahead on law and crime daily
everybody seemed to see a train wreck
coming but nobody seemed to know what to
do about it the defendant psychiatrist
takes the stand for the defense in the
olympian attempted murder trial out of
new jersey plus new details could lead
to answers and the unsolved murders out
of delphi indiana the most important
thing here
is finding out who perpetrated this
horrible crime that that's what
everybody wants and ohio versus william
hussell i'm just trying to make sure the
trial is fair ahead of closing arguments
we hear from the judge presiding over
the case but first a verdict is handed
down in the sarah lawrence college sex
cult federal trial long crime daily
covering court cases from coast to coast
[Music]
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm your host brian buckmeyer a verdict
is reached in the sarah lawrence sex
cult case in new york city not
surprisingly the accused cult leader
lawrence ray was found guilty on all
counts
a jury found the 62 year old defendant
guilty of a 15 count indictment of
federal charges related to the
manipulation and extortion of a group of
sarah lawrence college students
prosecutors say ray befriended the
students back in 2010 when he began
living with his daughter who was a
student at the college in all ray faced
17 charges including racketeering
extortion sex trafficking forced labor
and money laundering two counts were
dropped by the end of the trial for
technical reasons several of rey's
victims testified throughout the trial
telling jurors of the physical and
mental abuse ray forced upon them
including victim claudio jury who
testified to becoming a sex worker at
rey's urging ray's defense tried to
argue he took millions of dollars juror
earned doing sex work at an attorney's
advice saying it was restitution for a
jury allegedly trying to poison him the
mountain of evidence and exhibits
against rey led to the jury spending
just a few hours deliberating on
wednesday and returning a guilty verdict
ray faces life in prison for his alleged
crimes he's said to be sentenced in
september
joining us today is law and crime legal
analyst dr tracy pearson and co-host
terry austin dr pearson considering the
amount of evidence do you think maybe i
don't know it was a bit of a quick
verdict were you shocked at all at the
timing and how quickly the jury came
back with a guilty verdict
absolutely not i'm not shocked at all
and here's why the documentary evidence
that linked
the defendant to the crimes as well as
his own visual
appearance in these videos corroborated
the witness's testimony and and the
witness testimony was absolutely
emotionally damning and and
convincing for the jury i can't imagine
that in that that jury room they were
spending much time deliberating and in
fact spent most of their time filling
out the verdict form i mean i would
agree as well and terry i always have
this conversation with you
i wish i could be a fly on the wall in
the deliberation rooms what do you think
was going on in that room as jurors were
hashing out the verdict
you know what i agree with dr pearson
there's no question that that verdict
was going to come back the way it did
there was a ton of evidence particularly
those videos they were extremely
disturbing and i think they remembered
all of that and they couldn't get that
out of their minds they probably also
were going through some of the testimony
but they went through it very quickly
they could not forget claudia drury who
was up on that stand for days and the
fact that the brothers and sisters the
rosario siblings also were on the stand
they probably looked at some of that
testimony and talked about that as well
but frankly brian i think it was a
foregone conclusion they knew that it
was going to come back guilty this was
definitely a ton of evidence against him
yeah in a case like this i don't mean to
make light of the case like this but
oftentimes it takes them longer to get
lunch than it does for them to decide a
guilty verdict here and i think that
maybe is why it took a few hours but uh
we'll keep you updated on the lawrence
ray case as sentencing is coming up in
september and a florida judge rules the
jury will tour the inside of the marjory
stoneman douglas high school in parkland
florida as part of the sentencing phase
for defendant nicholas cruz on february
14 2018 crews opened fire in the school
killing 17 people and injuring 17 more
after the shooting spree parts of the
high school were blocked off and have
been since in the following years the
crime scene has actually been preserved
still showing bullet holes dried blood
and valentine's day's gifts that were
left behind by fleeing students in the
first week of jury selection judge
elizabeth shreer ruled it would be quote
useful and proper for the jury to tour
the scene something you'll be able to
see because of course the law and crime
network is set to cover the sentencing
phase live with gavital gavel coverage
when it begins on may 31st
still ahead on lawn crime daily more
than five years after two young girls
are murdered new answers could be
revealed in the delphi double homicide
case
but first closing arguments delayed for
the third time in the trial of ex-icu dr
william husso still ahead andrea lee
sits down with a judge presiding over
the case
[Music]
welcome back to law and crime daily once
again closing arguments in the trial of
william hussell have been pushed back
delayed until thursday at least we hope
law and crime's angela levy spoke with
the judge overseeing the case and tells
us what's being said about the delay
brian this is judge michael holbrook's
18th year on the bench before that he
told me he was a trial lawyer for 23
years now holbrook says he has tried
high profile cases in the past but the
william hussell case is more unique
because of the issues involved in the
science this is a doctor of course
accused of murdering 14 patients dr
husel
is says that he was providing comfort
care to those patients at the icu at
mount carmel hospital in columbus but he
prescribed doses of fentanyl that the
prosecutors say were actually lethal and
the prosecution says that some of these
patients were not even exhibiting signs
of pain
you have to handle like every other case
everybody else has the same rights
so that part the same
it's a little bit more complex issues
but
you know
i can't treat it like it's anything
special i just have to try the case make
it a fair try most of the evidence is in
the medical records and clearly he
ordered the injections it comes down to
what was his intent when he did it and
were they lethal doses that's what the
jury's basically
dealing with
i mean that's the big issue is did he
purposely caused the death of another
and
yeah he's a doctor who deals in death
but that's still the basic issue here
now closing arguments are scheduled for
thursday morning i asked judge
holbrook's staff attorney what was going
on with these multiple delays the only
thing she would tell me was that they
were still working through some issues
and when i spoke with judge holbrook he
told me that there are about 30 000
pages of medical records in this case
and that it would take some time to go
through the exhibits that would be sent
to the jury so we don't know if that
might have been a part of this delay
but obviously we'll have those closing
arguments covered for you when they
happen
brian
thanks anjanet let's bring back legal
analyst dr tracy pearson and terry
austin as the court tries to lock down
when closing arguments will start and
whoso terry eventually we'll have
closing arguments and when we do what do
you think will be the strongest
arguments on either side
i think the strongest argument for the
prosecution is going to be the fact that
he used fentanyl when most people used
other opioids like morphine and the
amount of fentanyl that he used was very
excessive and they had the members of
the families who died frankly up there
testifying saying that they felt as
though they were coerced they were
manipulated and so that's going to work
for the prosecution i think the defense
the strongest argument that the defense
has is the fact that this was comfort
care people understand and the jury
might understand that at the end of life
you want comfort care you don't want to
see your family member going through any
sort of pain and he was well regarded dr
healson was respected by his colleagues
so i also think that will play a factor
in favor of the defense yeah now dr
pearson it's not for a lack of trying
because angela has been all over this
trying to speak to clerks the judges
about what could possibly be pushing
this case back so let's speculate what
do you think it could be
well if i take out my crystal ball uh it
could come down to they are working
through jury instructions what will
those instructions say
when the judge instructs the jury on the
law
because there's a lot of science and
there are issues with with
the science as the judge discussed
the second thing that they could be
talking about is demonstratives um the
number of exhibits are huge and trying
to figure out uh what exhibits are going
to be used as demonstratives in each in
each closing uh may be the issue i
wouldn't hold out though that the idea
that possibly that they could in fact be
talking about potential um plea deal um
that is always a possibility in a
situation like this oh maybe we've got a
last minute or 11th hour plea and
jeanette give us a little bit more what
did judge holbrook have to say about the
lawyers for the prosecution and the
defense
you know it's funny brian i asked him
you know i said to him some people think
you were really annoyed
by jose baez and he's like i'm not
annoyed by jose baez or really any of
the other lawyers he said really
he was upset at times by some of the
behavior in the courtroom he said it was
addressed and he said it's interesting
to watch the different personalities and
the dynamics between these lawyers
particularly diane menashe and jose baez
the defense attorneys all right well
good thing we got that interview because
i would have thought that he had some
issues with jose baez but of course he's
telling us otherwise well thank you all
coming up on crime daily the defense may
soon rest its case in the olympian
attempted murder trial plus could new
information lead to a break in the case
we take a closer look at the unsolved
murders out of delphi indiana
[Music]
welcome back half a decade after two
young girls are brutally murdered in a
rural indiana town new information could
shed light on a potential suspect in the
case law on crime daily's sierra
gillespie joins us now to explain what
could be a break in the delphi double
homicide
it's a case that's captivated the nation
but has been unsolved for more than five
years but those following the
investigation closely tell me new
information could soon lead to answers
you think about how insulated delphi is
it's no cosmopolitan it's it's the heart
it's where stuff like this just doesn't
happen but on february 13 2017 the
sleepy town of delphi indiana changed
forever when thirteen-year-old abigail
williams and fourteen-year-old liberty
german went for a hike on a nearby trail
this snapchat photo is one of the last
known photos taken by the girls one day
later their bodies were discovered in a
double homicide that shook the midwest
in the more than five years since the
grisly murders few questions have been
answered including how they were killed
investigators releasing only this image
and brief video clip said to have been
taken by the girls while on the high
bridge
but in december of last year police
announced instagram and snapchat user
anthony schatz was connected to the case
later investigations found the real man
behind the account was 27-year-old kagan
klein who now faces more than 30 charges
relating to child pornography and
exploitation the newest twist in the
case came just last month when creators
of the murder sheet podcast uncovered a
deeper connection as i started reading
it and seeing those names and some of
the details i was just shocked and
horrified by what i was reading it was
pure coincidence that kevin greenlee and
anya kane stumbled upon the nearly 200
pages of interview documents where klein
admits to investigators he spoke with
liberty german on the day she was killed
there wasn't so much any single smoking
gun devastating detail but there was an
accumulation of little small things that
seemed one by one to
kind of build
a pretty strong case
for instance there were some
web searches that kagan did he did a
search on how long does dna last on a
body
that's an interesting thing for a person
who may be involved in a murder case to
be looking up behind the scenes you know
it seems like police conducted this very
well thought out interview with keg and
klein and i think there's been a lot of
online speculation that you know the
investigation has stalled or the police
aren't really doing anything and i i
think what at the very least this
transcript shows is that you know things
are moving in a certain direction at
this point and it looks like a lot of
work is being done
toward that end forensic death
investigator joseph scott morgan has
covered the case since it broke in 2017.
he says dna could be the key to solving
the murders
even when you have a negative finding
in say testing and forensics that's a
good thing
because
immediately you can eliminate things
and that that puts you down a different
path so there there is no good or bad
when you think about negative positive
it's it's what direction is it
ultimately going to take the
investigation but the search for answers
in the case still as crucial as ever
anybody
that would do this
is still out there they
need
to be removed from the general
population it is in my view they're
dangerous they're very very dangerous
indiana state police won't confirm the
contents of that newly released
interview and say it wasn't put out by
police or the delphi double homicide
task force right now the investigation
into the murders is still ongoing
reporting for law and crime network i'm
sierra gillespie
law and crime legal analyst dr traci
pearson and co-host terry austin join us
again as we examine new documents in the
search of a murderer terry do these new
documents point to a strong new lead or
unfortunately or potentially another
dead end in trying to solve this murder
mystery
look this looks like one of the
strongest leads they've had so far they
now have a name kagan klein that is huge
they also know where he is and with that
information they can do the dna evidence
they can do forensic evidence
and they've interviewed him already so
they can trace back everything that he
said in all of those documents they know
what his physical stature is they know
the clothing that he was wearing on that
day and fortunately we have that video
that libby took the last thing she did
probably before she died so hopefully
they can get to it
yeah well dr pearson to terry's point
the law enforcement seems to have
something to lease to work with so
what's likely to be their next move in
solving these murders
there's a saying sunlight is the best
disinfectant and with the release of
this transcript and the publication of
it it's going to bring people forward
who may have information
so the police will be up taking
telephone calls and receiving tips uh
and be sussing those out that'll lead to
more forensic evidence like digital
evidence uh
like was found uh on instagram and on
snapchat uh and with more evidence it'll
be able to establish a much clearer path
uh to locating the suspect and uh
charging that individual to get them off
the streets yeah let's hope with more
eyes and more sunlight as you said in
this case we get more answers as this
case develops
when we come back a jury in new jersey
may soon begin deliberating in the
olympian attempted murder trial still
ahead on law and crime daily who the
defense calls as some of his final
witnesses
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back the defense team calls the
defendant psychiatrist to the stand in
the ongoing new jersey trial for
olympian mike or ex-olympian sorry
michael barrisson barristone is facing
two counts of attempts in murder after
he shot lauren canorack in the chest
twice and shot her then boyfriend robert
goodwin back in 2019. the dispute
followed ongoing back and forth
arguments about canarac and goodwin's
living arrangement on barriston's farm
at the time of the shooting the two were
living in an apartment on barriston's
property while he trained canarak in
dressage horseback riding barristone's
defense team argued he feared for his
life at the time of the shooting and
suffered from mental health issues the
defendant psychiatrist testified on
wednesday about the deteriorating
relationship between barizone and
kanorak and on cross-examination he told
jurors about the pattern which emerged
in barisone
doctor you testified on direct
examination that
mr barrissone was depressed and
preoccupied
with uh
ms canary
and you
based that in part on
review of the
various facebook posts and social media
posts that he told you that he was
reviewing well that statements by other
witnesses i can't name all of them but
there were a lot of people who were
interviewed who were seeing the same
thing and felt helpless to do anything
about it everybody seemed to see a train
wreck coming but nobody seemed to know
what to do about it people on the farm
were concerned about the welfare of
michael barrasso and they saw the man
they really cared for deteriorating but
they were not concerned about their
personal safety it was only barrisol who
was afraid
that lauren canorack was going to kill
him he was the only one that was afraid
correct
that he was going to be killed by
cataract
dr pearson i'm watching barisone's body
language and we've got to assume because
the case is moving forward he's
competent to stand trial but as you see
him are there some question marks about
that
yes i i would agree with you he's
presumed competent however the lawyer if
if he is not able to assist in his
defense would have to bring that to the
court's attention
i think that uh what is most concerning
to me is that having been a trial lawyer
you're engaging with your client and
although he isn't on the camera isn't on
the lawyer at all times um
and with the client at all times because
we're looking at the witness i am
concerned about the body language
because there isn't a connection between
the two of them and you would think that
there would be
yeah it seems very bizarre terry dr
simmering was on the stand most of the
morning do you think his testimony
supported the claim that barriston was
mentally ill at the time of the shooting
you know i i really thought dr simmering
was an excellent witness for the defense
he was brilliant his background columbia
nyu bellevue and not only that he had
the psychiatry but he was also an expert
in forensic psychiatry so that means he
can put the law together with that
psychiatry so he also testified for both
the defense and the prosecution he even
mentioned that he had testified for
christopher shellhorn who is the
prosecutor in this case so i thought he
reviewed all the documents spoke to
everyone who was involved he said that
he spoke to barroson five times just
alone and so i thought he had all the
background information and most
importantly brian he was able to
establish that based on all of the
review of all of that evidence that
there was delusional disorder and
persistent depressive disorder all that
you need that he didn't know the
difference between right and wrong yeah
i've never seen a defense and mental
illness defense work together but we'll
see
thank you for joining us here on law on
crime daily we'll see you next time as
we discuss justice in america
[Music]
you